>>Leslie: Thank you everybody for coming today.
This is obviously the latest in our electoral
series of candidate visits.
I am honored to have Kamala Harris here with
us. She is running for State Attorney General.
She is San Francisco's District Attorney and
has held that office since 2003.
Prior to that she worked in San Francisco
both for the City and District Attorney's
Office, as well as Alameda.
She is the Democratic nominee and after a
hard fought campaign with-with a number of
folks it's nice to see her here. And we are
going to have Steve Cooley on campus next
week. We wanna make sure that we are fair
to both sides.
And I just wanna say really quick before I
pass this over to David.
For some of you who may wonder does-does the
AG in California matter or impact our work.
And yes, the AG does. So when you think of
topics: anti-trust; piracy; privacy; patents;
we are always involved in interacting with
the AG and it's my hope that our next AG will
actually become a very strong ambassador to
the Attorneys General in a number of other
states. It's something where we have growing
relationships there, but to have our home
state AG speak on the industry's behalf will
be very important to us.
And with that I pass it over to David.
>>David: Well thanks Leslie. And thanks everybody
for coming. I'm really, really honored to-to
have Kamala Harris here at-at-at Google. She's
someone I've known for some time and is one
of our-our State's really fabulous public
servants and officials.
And so we're, we really wanna get a chance
to let her share her vision about the State,
the race that she's currently in and to give,
I've got a few questions and I'll-I'll try
to do my Charlie Rose routine here --
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs]
>>David: but we really wanna hear from you
guys
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>David: too, so-so why don't we just kick
it off.
Fir, you're a native Californian. You're-you're
running for Attorney General. Some people
might see the Attorney General's Office as
-- well it's that lawyer thing.
>>Kamala Harris: Uh-hum.
>>David: But it-it really is an important
position, right and has remarkable influence
on what-what goes on in our State. So I-I
wanted to ask you first off, why are you running?
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs] 'Cause I wanna do
the job.
>>David: Okay.
>>Kamala Harris: I actually really wanna do
the job.
And why I'm running, another part of the answer
is-is the same reason that I became a prosecutor.
>>David: Um.
>>Kamala Harris: I'm one of two daughters
of parents who met when they were graduate
students at the University of California Berkeley
in the 1960's.
[laughs]
>>David: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: Not your peers. And-and they
met when they were actively involved in the
Civil Rights Movement.
So that meant that my sister and I grew up
pretty much surrounded by adults who spent
full-time marching and shouting about this
thing we call justice. And growing up in that
environment, the heroes for me were the architects
of the Civil Rights Movement. And-and they
were the lawyers.
So it was Charles Hamilton Houston and Thurgood
Marshall and Constance Baker Motley who were
taking the skill of this great profession
of law and translating the passion from the
street to the courtrooms of our country.
And reminding the people, who unfortunately
needed to be reminded, of that great promise
we articulated in 1776, which is that we are
all and should be treated and seen as equals.
So I decided I wanted to be a lawyer at a
very young age. Went to Howard University
and then I came back home to San Francisco
and attended UC Hastings. And out of law school
I made the decision to become a prosecutor.
And you can imagine if you any sense of who
my family is that that was a --
>>David: Right. Yeah,
>>Kamala Harris: curious decision. [laughs]
>>David: exactly.
>>Kamala Harris: In some ways I had to defend
--
>>David: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: the decision like one would
a thesis.
But what I said then is what I absolutely
maintain today after a career as a prosecutor
which is that law enforcement has such a profound
and direct impact on the most vulnerable among
us, and has as its responsibility, as its
job, to be a voice for the voiceless. And
in the process of giving voice also give dignity.
And so that's the work that I decided I wanted
to do.
>>David: Uh-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: And-and I have prosecuted
many cases. From the ground up I've been in-in
many courtrooms talking with juries about
why in a civil and-and just society, there
will be severe and swift consequences when
one human being kills another human being
or if a woman is raped or a child is molested.
And talking about why that work is important
if we are going to be committed to justice,
which is the work of defending and being a
voice for our most vulnerable.
>>David: Right.
So-so again this is-this, you're running for
a really important position --
>>Kamala Harris: Yes.
>>David: in our, in our State so why don't
you tell us a little bit about what you think
are California's biggest challenges --
>>Kamala Harris: Sure.
>>David: and biggest opportunities right now?
>>Kamala Harris: Sure. The general point that
I'd make about our challenges is that I think
for-for too long we in government and in public
offices have-have not embraced what you have
embraced which is the importance of innovation.
You know if you look at any elected who's
up for reelection, they will not take a political
knock for doing things the way they've always
been done. "Good for you Bob, you're doing
things the way they've always been done."
To engage in innovation in a position such
as mine means to engage in what you all do
which is by definition to bring to bear some
new idea or method or device.
Well what we all know about that process is
that when one is engaged in innovation, no
matter how well thought out, well planned,
well conceived your idea may be, when you
roll it out for the first time there will
probably be a glitch.
But when you hold a position such as mine,
you will read about that glitch on the front
page of the newspaper, which means that when
you hold these positions there is a great
assumption of risk to take on innovation.
And unless you have the courage combined hopefully
with some political capital there are seemingly
few rewards for engaging in innovation, which
is, which is really unfortunate.
My mother was a scientist. There is this wonderful
word that has a great meaning and it's called
"hypothesis", [laughs] which means that you
have an idea and then it is well accepted,
it will be tested --
>>David: Uh-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: and then you will learn whether
it was correct or not but there will be no
pride associated with the hypothesis because
after all it was a hypothesis [laughs] --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: and then you will reconvene
and then create a new hypothesis.
>>David: Right. Right.
>>Kamala Harris: But in government --
>>David: We like to call it iteration --
>>Kamala Harris: in law enforcement --
>>David: at Google.
>>Kamala Harris: Right, right exactly. Right.
>>David: It's how we operate.
>>Kamala Harris: But in-in government you
know when you have that idea you better stick
with it and defend it at all cost. And there
is also part of the culture that suggests
that you are doing a good job if you are strictly
adhering to tradition as opposed to measuring
effectiveness with the infusion of metrics
to look at whether we are actually producing
what we all have the desire will be produced.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: So if I can just keep going
-
>>David: Yeah, no, please, please. No this
is great.
>>Kamala Harris: An example of-of-of-of what
I am talking about in practice is in California
on an annual basis, we release 120,000 prisoners
because they have served their time. Within
three years of their release, 70 percent reoffend.
The word for that is recidivism. Seventy percent
recidivate. It's the highest recidivism rate
in the country.
So I think what is obvious about this is that
anything with a seven out of ten failure rate
is demanding some reconfiguration.
But the other point is that it is extremely
expensive this failure. In terms of what it
is costing us in a state that is on the verge
of bankruptcy, it's a $10 billon dollar slice
in the annual budget. It is also extremely
expensive in terms of what it is costing our
public safety.
So knowing that, I decided to create a re-entry
unit in my office which is one of the only
re-entry units of a DA's office; and decided
to focus on the 18 through 24 year old, first
time, low level, non-violent drug sales offender;
called it "The Initiative Back on Track".
Why that population? Well, when I was at Howard
University when we were all in college, we
were 18 through 24, and we were called "college
kids".
But when you're 18 and you turn 18 and you're
in the system, you are considered an adult.
Period. Regardless of the fact that is the
very phase of life in which we have invested
billions of dollars in this world in those
places called colleges and universities, knowing
that as the prime phase of life, during which
we mold and shape and direct a human being
to become a productive adult.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: So what I did is I called
up a bunch of friends in the business community,
the Chamber of Commerce, I called up other
folks in the building trades unions, and called
up some of our faith based and community non-profits.
And we addressed the fact that in this population
which is a very large population in the criminal
justice system, a lot of them needed to get
a GED and be enrolled in city college. Almost
none of them have employable skills. So we
enrolled them in the apprenticeship programs
offered by the carpenters and the plumbers.
And David, I'm gonna ask you if you --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: can create an apprenticeship
program for [ ]too.
>David: Right. [chuckles]
>>Kamala Harris: We-we-we dealt with the fact
that they also many of them are parents who
have a natural desire to parent their children,
but not necessarily the skills. So we brought
on board community based folks to work on
that.
Over the course of the last five years this
Initiative Back on Track has reduced the re-offense
rate for this population from 54 percent to
less than 10 percent.
It's been so successful that the National
DA's Association and the United States Department
of Justice have designated it as a model of
innovation for law enforcement in the United
States.
But there are risks associated with that.
>>David: Sure.
>>Kamala Harris: I will tell you it was on
the front page of a newspaper when one of
the offenders a couple years into the program
went out and committed a horrendous crime.
And he happened to also be an undocumented
immigrant.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: And so then someone wrote
an article and said, "Kamala Harris has created
a program to shield undocumented immigrants."
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: Right? These are the risks
one --
>>David: Sure.
>>Kamala Harris: assumes when they do something
differently in government.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: But I think that we are at
a place in time and especially in this great
state where we cannot afford to do business
the way it has been done. We cannot afford
to maintain status quo because we are really
looking at a lot of broken systems and this
is where the culture of Google --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: and-and the work that you
all do is so very important and has to be
shared with a, with a much bigger audience
and in particular with people who hold offices
like mine. Which is that the best way that
you become excellent --
>>David: Yeah.
>>Kamala Harris: and-and create models and
improve the lives of people is when you are
willing to invest in innovation and-and encourage
a standard of business that is not based on
an adherence to tradition, --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: but instead based on what
is your reason for being.
>>David: Right. Right.
Well in some, in some of your answers, you
were touching on some of the-the themes of-of
your book that --
>>Kamala Harris: Yes.
>>David: that-that came out last year, "Smart
on Crime". And can you expand a little bit
more on-on some of this? I mean your-your
,one of your basic points was that law enforcement
is not the only answer --
>>Kamala Harris: Correct.
>>David: to reducing crime. Can you talk a
little bit more-more about that?
>>Kamala Harris: So the public health model
is a tested, try and true model. That tells
us about a health epidemic. What I think we
should think about when we think about a crime
epidemic.
Public health model tells us this: health
epidemic; best way to deal with it, prevention.
If the sniffles take hold, early intervention,
but if we're at the point of dealing with
it in the emergency room, it's too late and
it's too expensive.
So too for criminal justice policy.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: We have to recognize that
we have been I think misguided for a long
time in terms of how we categorize one's criminal
justice policy perspective. We have suggested
there are only two. You are either tough on
crime or you're soft on crime. Instead of
asking, "Are we smart on crime?" Thus, the
title of my book.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: Which means let us recognize
absolutely, let's react with certainty and
swiftly after a crime has occurred. I've raised
the conviction rates in my office to the highest
they've been in 15 years, in particular for
serious and violent crime. I have personally
prosecuted homicide cases. I am all about
lockin' up somebody who rapes a woman, molests
a child, or murders a human being.
That being said, I took an oath to be concerned
about public safety and your safety. And if
I'm gonna be most effective that way, I cannot
be limited to reacting after a crime occurs.
We must also be equally invested with the
equal amount of passion in preventing a crime
before it occurs. But status quo has suggested
that the way that one is effective in these
positions is to talk tough.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: Talk tough around reacting
and then if you talk about other issues that's
soft.
Well I would suggest to you that's misguided
and incorrect. So the book I wrote divides
it into, they're two halves. And-and so the
first half I have several chapters that address
which I believe are myths about the criminal
justice system that have impeded better and
smarter criminal justice policy.
In the second half of the book I talk about
best practices from around the country.
So an example of a myth. It's a, the, a myth,
children are resilient.
So we have public policy that has been built
up around the idea that whatever happens to
a child, they'll grow out of it. Or-or look
at little Johnny> He's playing in the playground;
he's fine. Instead of recognizing that whatever
especially traumatic event happens to a child
--
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: will ever be imprinted in
the life of that person if we don't take seriously
what is happening with that child when they
are a child.
But you see we have marginalized issues that
impact children. We have decided I guess because
they're small people, those are small issues.
Or we have decided that's something women
care about or parents care about or people
who care about cute, cuddly things care about.
Instead of recognizing it is smarter, it is
more effective, and it is cheaper to address
an issue that impacts a child while they are
a child than to wait until they become the
adult who everyone's knocking on my door about.
When what happened when they were six would
have absolutely predicted what they're doing
when they're 16.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: So an example of that is
an initiative that I started, I'm just just
goin' --
>>David: No, no. Keep goin'. Keep goin'.
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs]
>>David: I'm gonna stop you in a minute.
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs] Okay.
An example of this is I did an assessment
of who the homicide victims were in San Francisco
who are under the age of 25 when they were
killed. 'Cause we had a rash of homicides
and I wanted to know what's going on here?
Who are they? Let's not just accept this.
Well, I learned the data came back 94 percent
of them are high school drop-outs.
So then I went over to the school district
and I asked the superintendent, "What's going
on?" She said, "Well Kamala of the few of
number of children we have in the public school
system in San Francisco, 5500 have been designated
as habitually and chronically truant and of
the 5500, 2400 are elementary school students;
missing, by the way, 60, 70, 80 days of a
180 day school year.
So I asked the superintendent to convene a
meeting for me with all the principals and
administrators of the San Francisco Unified
School District and she did. And I stood before
them in a high school auditorium, a local
high school auditorium, and I shared with
them a fact about myself. I'm a product of
California Public Schools and my first grade
teacher, Mrs. Frances Wilson, God rest her
soul, attended my law school graduation.
>>David: Hum.
>>Kamala Harris: I would not be standing here
or sitting here were it not for the education
I received. And I believe a child going without
an education is tantamount to a crime. So
I declared that I've decided I'm gonna start
prosecuting parents for truancy. Well if you
all know --
>>David: [chuckles]
>>Kamala Harris: anything --
>>David: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: about San Francisco politics
you'll know half the room booed and the other
half stood up and clapped. And let me tell
you, but and my staff went bananas because
it was before we knew if I was gonna have
an opponent in my re-election race, they were
like: "Can't you wait. Everyone's gonna be
mad at you."
>>David: [chuckles]
>>Kamala Harris: I said: "Look. I'm done.
And I've got some political capital and I'm
gonna spend some of it." And this is what
we did.
Well one of the things about my job is the
job comes with a badge and there is an artistic
rendering of said badge on my stationary.
So on my letterhead I sent out to every parent
in the San Francisco Unified School District
a letter outlining the direct connection between
elementary school truancy, high school dropout
rates, who will be a victim of crime, who
will be a perpetrator of crime.
So a friend of mine called me up, he said:
"Kamala my wife got the letter. She freaked
out. She called all the kids into the living
room --
>>David: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: held up the letter, said:
"If you don't go to school --
>>David: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: Kamala's gonna put you and
me in jail."
[laughter]
Intended effect.
And then what we also did, my friend, is we
set up what we call the DA Mediation Program
where I assign prosecutors to go and meet
with the principals when they were meeting
with these hundreds of parents.
Now remember this had never been done in my
office before. So when I created it, I had
to take volunteers from my office. You know
the prosecutors who volunteered? My gang prosecutors
and my homicide prosecutors. And so I'd say,
"When you go over there look really mean"
which wasn't hard 'cause they look like they're
mean dudes.
>>David: [chuckles]
>>Kamala Harris: And so they were standing
there and the parent was like, "Well who's
the mean lookin' dude?" And there's like,
"That's someone that mean DA Kamala Harris
sent over here 'cause she said she's gonna
start prosecuting you if we can't work this
out."
And this is what we found: we found cases
like the case of the woman who by herself
was raising her three children, holding down
two jobs, and homeless. She just needed some
help.
But by shining this infrared light of our
public safety on the fact that her children
are not in school --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: and asking the question about
why her children aren't in school, we were
able to figure it out and get her access to
services that exist. Of course her children's
attendance improved. We dismissed the charges
against her and over the course of this initiative,
we have improved attendance for this population,
which has been the elementary and middle school
population, by 30 percent.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: So I would suggest that there
are many approaches that we can take recognizing
the power of these offices and also recognizing
that-that we can have some impact if we are
willing to have the courage to reconfigure
so that we don't, we don't run away from our
core function, but also realize how we can
actually do better.
>>David: Right. Great.
Well I wanted to-to, I'm sure that issue's
going to come up again in --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>David: the Q and A period, but --
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs]
>>David: and-and I wanna get back to issues
again in a minute, but I wanna talk for a
minute about the race, a little bit.
So your opponent, you're the, you're the DA-DA
of San Francisco, your opponent's the District
Attorney of Los Angeles.
Some might say similar resumes and so-so what-what
are the differences? I mean, how do you, how
do you, what's, how's the State gonna be better
if-if you're the Attorney General and-and
not Mr. Cooley?
>>Kamala Harris: Well I know that I read that
at the Republican Convention he called me
a radical. So I guess that's one difference
[laughs] between us. And yeah, I am a radical.
[chuckles]
>>David: [chuckles] Okay.
>>Kamala Harris: I do believe that we need
to get radical about what we are doing --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: and take it seriously.
>>Kamala Harris: I'd say the difference between
us is really the difference between the defense
of status quo.
>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: And-and what we should be
willing to do to be critical of existing systems
and then adopt innovation and move forward.
So, for example, one of my key areas of focus
which will not be the subject of any television
commercial we do because it, this is the other
thing about politics of running for office.
It's, it can be very frustrating as a candidate
because the public appetite is and-and the
way the system is set up is that the most
people I can talk with will be. I will be
able to talk with them through television,
right?
When I ran for DA in San Francisco I was at
bus stops shakin' hands at six o'clock in
the morning. This is the largest geographically
and by population size, largest state in the
country. I -- the only way that I will shake
the hand of every voter is through television,
at a cost of two million dollars a week, by
the way. It's-it's crazy. And we need to talk
to them for at least six weeks.
So that being said, television commercials
become the key and-and way that we speak with
voters. Well those television commercials
are exactly 30 seconds. And so its gonna,
it's a challenge for someone like me because
there's a lot I obviously wanna talk about
to-to be able to communicate with voters around
the priorities. That being said, that's a
long way of saying.
One of my priorities that will probably not
be the subject of any television commercial
because it probably falls under the category
of the mundane, seemingly mundane, is this
important issue of the adoption of technology
by law enforcement in particular and government
in general.
When I was elected District Attorney of San
Francisco in 2004, San Francisco, the first
cousin to Silicon Valley, two-thirds of my
lawyers did not have email. We are still rolling
out email in the San Francisco Police Department.
This is the reality of it.
The reality of it is when you pull back the
way government works, pull that curtain back,
it's like watchin' that little guy in the
Wizard of Oz. It's an amazing thing anything
gets done. It is extremely obsolete in the
way that our systems are functioning and there
has to be change.
And the Attorney General of the State of California
can provide that kind of leadership and change.
And why is that important? It's obvious, the
obvious point is-is that we -- anything should
be upgraded from the 20th to the 21st century.
But-but let's make a more practical reason
for why it's important. I'll give you two
reasons specifically that I think most people
would appreciate.
One, police officer is pulling someone over
for a broken tail light. Well that person
is wanted in another jurisdiction for an armed
robbery. That police officer probably won't
know that. So that presents the challenge
of: one, police officer is risking his life
when he gets out of the car to write that
ticket 'cause that driver knows what he's
wanted for. Two, God willing the police officer
goes back. He's safe. Armed robbery's just
gone free.
Another side of that coin is one of the biggest
and most prevalent crimes that is occurring
in our state and in our country and going
without consequence is identify theft.
>>David: Yeah
>>Kamala Harris: And you know why it's going
without consequence? Because the infrastructure
has not the skills to do all of the work that
is necessary to put those crimes together.
It's that basic. It's that basic.
There has to be an adoption of technology
by law enforcement and government in general
if for no other reason because we know that
the best tool that we have in most systems
and particular in govern, in government and
law enforcement, is-is our ability to communicate.
And isn't that the very core reason for being
of technology which is to allow us to communicate
effectively and efficiently and with speed
--
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: and accuracy?
So that's another priority for me. I don't,
you can ask him what he thinks about these
things, but I haven't heard him talk about
it.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: You know there's another
issue that would be a very big difference
between us.
I-I, and I've challenged him for the last
six months. He's not taken a position in terms
of AB 32, which is a law that we passed with
bipartisan support in California --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: to say that we want high
standards around greenhouse gas emissions.
That we want to be a leader and that we wanna
hold our self, as a, as a State strictly accountable
so that we can reduce and we can encourage
green technologies and we can en-encourage
all of the work that you all are doing here
around, in-in this area and other parts of
the State --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: around solar panel tech,
and-and building economies and all of this,
right? Well this is what AB 32 would encourage
and-and-and facilitate.
There is a proposition on the November ballot
called Proposition 23 which would push as
it purports a pause button on AB 32, but I
will tell you, it will kill AB 32.
My opponent has failed --
>>David: People should know Google is-is-is
on record against the-the --
>>Kamala Harris: That's great.
>>David: Prop 23.
And my opponent refuses to take a position
on that.
When I was first elected DA, I created an
environmental justice unit --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: for the same reason. We have
to upgrade the way we think of our-our-our
responsibility. My job is to absolutely protect
my constituency from all the crimes we've
already discussed, but as important and imminent
a threat to your health and safety as is any
crime we've discussed, so too are crimes being
committed against our environment.
And so we have to create a-an institutional
commitment to that issue. And that means creating
units where there is a special, specialization
that is cultivated and enhanced and-and grown.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: I've done that.
>>David: Right, right.
>>Kamala Harris: He has dis, decimated --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: his unit in his office --
>>Kamala Harris: and has not taken a position
on AB --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: 32.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: I think that's a problem.
>>David: Yeah.
>>Kamala Harris: I think it's a problem that
he has said that he will join with southern
states attorneys general and join the suit
challenging the administration's health care
reform.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: Which of course I think is
an absolute misuse of limited resources in
this state and not in the best interest of
the people in this state, a lot of whom are
uninsured and-and who need access to affordable
health care.
And-and when the Attorney General in the State
of California starts weighing in on these
very, very important issues that have national
implication, when the Attorney General weighs
in of California, that's the big dog.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: And it can be a game changer.
So all of those issues I think are very much
at play in this election and differences between
he and I.
>>David: Now I assume that-that you-you probably
also differ on Prop 8 and --
>>Kamala Harris: Oh, absolutely.
>>David: and --
>>Kamala Harris: And, but he has said --
>>David: whether or not that should be defended?
>>Kamala Harris: Thank you.
>>David: Yes.
>>Kamala Harris: And he's said, he has said
he would defend Prop 8.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: I have been very clear in
my opposition to Prop 8 and at this point
in time I think it is, it is, it is inappropriate
at best for anyone running for Attorney General
in the State of California to say they would
do anything other --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: than stand down when a federal
judge has said that it is unconstitutional.
Again with limited resources in a state that
is on the verge of bankruptcy, one should
not be using the resources, the limited resources
and power of that office to defend a law that
has been found by a judge to be unconstitutional.
A law that, by the way, the current Attorney
General and current Governor have agreed are,
is-is an unconstitutional law.
So --
>>David: So let me, let's talk about the politics
of the --
>>Kamala Harris: [unintelligible]
>>David: race for a second. Yes. So-so a lot
of differences pretty clear choice here, but
a little bit about the politics of the race.
So he's from L.A., L.A. elected official,
in L.A. County, the biggest county --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>David: in the state. You've got a statewide
at the top of the Republican ticket. You have
a candidate who's spending lots and lots of-of
money, what-what do you need to do to win?
>>Kamala Harris: It's so crude, David. I need
to raise a ton of money.
>>David: Um.
>>Kamala Harris: It's-it's-it's just, it's
the reality of-of running statewide and there
is no other way to talk with voters other
than talking with them through television.
>>David: Um.
>>Kamala Harris: And it's so extremely expensive.
And-and for all I have said about my disagreements
with my opponent, I will say this, I take
him very seriously and he's ab-absolutely
formidable.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: He's in his third term as
District Attorney of Los Angeles.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: It is the county with the
largest population in the state and so he
is a very significant opponent. We are neck
and neck in the polling. Right now there is
one poll that shows him about three points
ahead of us which means statistically we're
in a dead heat.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: We're neck and neck in fund
raising. And-and there is a lot at stake.
And I should add because the commercials will
start airing soon anyway, so he's gonna start
adding all these, running all these hit pieces
against me as he's been talking about in all
these meetings.
I am personally opposed to the death penalty,
but as I've said I will follow the law and
my position on the death penalty is the same
as four of the last nine Attorneys General.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: My opponent will use that
as a soft on crime card to suggest that I
am not committed to doing the work that needs
to be done by law enforcement, which is absolutely
incorrect as evidenced by the fact that I
have the highest conviction rates that we've
had.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: So there are a lot of issue
that are gonna come up that are gonna be red
herrings in this campaign because I will tell
you that among the many important issues that
people are facing right now, at the top of
that list, is jobs, is, they want more efficient
systems. I've done a whole body of work around
mortgage fraud.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: Let's talk about that for
an example.
There are all these families in this state
who are doing everything they were supposed
to do to live the American dream.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: And the American dream tells
us and told them, "Go out and buy a home.
Pay your bills on tack, on time, you taxes
on time, your mortgage on time." And they
did all that. And then they found they were
out of work. And there are predators who have
come in in the form of brokers to financial
institutions who have literally stripped these
folks of their few remaining assets and all
their dignity. And this is another crime that
has gone absolutely without consequence based
on its prevalence.
I have a whole body of work in my office doing
that. It's been so successful that we applied
for a very competitive grant from the Federal
Government which we brought home to San Francisco
to create a stand-alone mortgage fraud unit;
a million dollar grant.
>>David: Um.
>>Kamala Harris: So I've done that work. I
would suggest to you that's a priority. I
would suggest to you the-the conversation
we're having about the environment is a priority.
I would suggest to you that there is a huge
priority around making clear the connection
between public safety and public education
and using the power and the bully pulpit of
the office to say, "You care about your personal
safety. Well then you really should care about
the education of other people's children."
These are very, very important issues and
I promise you that the way that you will see
the attacks come at us will be to bait people
into extreme ideological ends instead of to
talk about what is just practically --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: what we should be discussing
and be concerned about. And in this way I
do see most of these issues as non-partisan,
to be honest.
>>David: Right. Right.
>>Kamala Harris: I, and I think for too long
we have suggested that they-they-they are
partisan or ideological issues, when they're
not. I've never seen anybody go up and-and
before they rob somebody ask them what-what
party they're registered to.
Just doesn't happen.
>>David: No. Fair enough.
So before we open it up to audience questions
I wanted to cover a couple of-of other basically
non-partisan issues.
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: that we, that-that address some of
the things we do around-around --
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>David: the shop here at Google.
One of those is on-line privacy.
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: Now in the primary I know you had
criticized your opponent --
>>Kamala Harris: Yes.
>>David: for-for sort of bein' lax and-and
not sufficiently concerned, if you will --
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: about on-line privacy or violations
of on-line privacy with social --
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: networks and so forth. So we wanna
hear from you a little bit about how-how you
think about that issue --
>>Kamala Harris: Sure.
>>David: and given how quickly the technology's
moving how, given how-how powerful a lot of
these tools are, if you have a vision for
regulating it or doing something to enforce
a law around it. How do you do that? How do
you think about that and how do you do that
without stifling the kind of innovation --
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>David: that-that you're seeing in this whole
area?
>>Kamala Harris: So as a lawyer you know we
all know the Constitution of the United States
has a Fourth Amendment and that is the-the-the-the
law that surrounds what is reasonable and
unreasonable search and seizure.
And so underlying all of the, any analysis
about would be what would be a reasonable
or unreasonable taking of your stuff by government
or anybody else, is the concept of what is
a reasonable expectation of privacy.
So the laws that have been written and are
on the books to deal with this issue of privacy
are laws that developed primarily, and this
gets back to the 20th century versus the 21st
century --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: world, right? The laws are
still very much grounded in the 20th century
--
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: and-and before.
So the laws that came up around privacy were
developed around literally the structure of
a house. Well what can you see from the street
if you were looking through the window of
that house versus what you would be able to
see or take if you opened the door of that
house versus what -- right? What is your reason,
what, versus what you're doing in the front
yard of that house.
>>David: True.
>>Kamala Harris: And so what expectation of
privacy do you attach to whatever is placed
in that particular place as it relates to
that house?
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: So given where we are now,
so you're now, no longer are you necessarily
keeping those private files in some file cabinet
that's locked in the basement of the house.
It's on your laptop and it's then therefore
up here in this cloud that exists above us,
right?
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: It's no longer in a physical
place. And so we have to, lawyers, judges,
government, realize that ti-times are changing.
>>David: Sure.
>>Kamala Harris: And we have, we're gonna
have to figure out a way to adapt. And-and
adapt to the realities of where we are.
Other laws that-that deal with, for example,
copyright, existed in theft, let's use theft
as an example. Well theft was always and-and
our laws regarding theft were-were always
based on the idea that I would take something
from you --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: and deprive you of-of possession
of that thing.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: Well now because of technology
I can take something from you because I copy
it, but you still have it. Right?
>>David: Yeah. So you're takin' the value
of it. Right.
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>David: Yeah.
>>Kamala Harris: And so but we haven't adjusted
and-and-and ?
>>David: [unintelligible]
>>Kamala Harris: frankly part of the problem
I think is also that-that there's a-a lack
of understanding of what you all do, by me
and many others.
>>David: Yeah.
>>Kamala Harris: And-and that's some, that's
a gap that has to be recognized and we have
to do something consciously --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: to close that gap.
>>David: I mean 'cause one of the concerns,
I mean you go  back to privacy you-you
said times are changing and it's 21st century
is very different than --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>David: the 20th century. Well one of the
ways in which its different is people have
a lot more interest or a lot, a lot less concern
about making information that heretofore was
private either because they wanted it to be
private or because it was simply obscure right
--
>>Kamala Harris: That's right.
>>David: and hard to find.
>>Kamala Harris: That's exactly right.
>>David: And now --
>>Kamala Harris: That's right.
>>David: technology makes it easy to find
--
>>Kamala Harris: That's right.
>>David: and in a lot of cases the culture
there are arguments about whether the culture
really is changing.
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: But people wanna --
>>Kamala Harris: That's a --
>>David: wanna share more.
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah. Yep.
>>David: So it, so the concern of-of a lot
of folks in the Valley and who-who work in
this area is that law enforcement, government,
policy makers are going to do things to protect
users --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>David: and people from themselves because
there's some sense of 20th century privacy
that has to be protected.
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: How do you, how do you respond to
that?
>>Kamala Harris: That there's a balance that
has to be struck.
>>David: Yeah.
>>Kamala Harris: So one of the issues that
has come up that-that is a kind of high profile
issue on this point, it-it-it relates to children
and their use of technology in a way that
may harm them. And so I would suggest to you
based on the work that I've done that the
best way to deal with that is prevention --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: which means educating the
parents and teachers and the community that
is raising that child to understand the technology
in a way that they can teach the child what
we otherwise teach children when we cross
the street: "Don't just look at the light,
look both ways before you cross. Don't talk
to a stranger and-and the stranger is someone
you've never seen before." But "stranger"
is defined a little differently when you're
interacting with someone on a social networking
site.
>>David: Right. Right.
>>Kamala Harris: So that's part of it.
>>David: Right:
>>Kamala Harris: And I think the other part
of it is just also having some commitment
to an understanding that the technology that
is coming right out of our backyard, and this
is where I have a certain bravado about being
a California kid. I mean I do. Which is its
right here and the next Attorney General of
California should be the-the-the go to person
for how we should be handling these cases
--
>>David: Okay.
>>Kamala Harris: in the country and-and in
that way I approach my thoughts about this
with a deep understanding that we're just
at the beginning --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: of-of where this can go ?
>>David: [unintelligible]
>>Kamala Harris: and we really don't wanna
stand in a, in-in the way of its potential
and its development.
You know like what's happening now with broadband
--
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: and how that's gonna change.
The potential and the expanse and-and availability
it's profound. And-and so there has to be
come balance struck between what is an immediate
issue that is literally causing harm to the
lives of people --
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: versus to your point changing
laws to adapt to those points that you've
made.
>>David: Right.
Well let-let me actually, I wanna open it
up in a minute. I'm gonna ask one more question
and then people can, we've got mics on either
side, so as I'm asking this question and-and-and
Kamala's answering, maybe you could get up
and prepare yours.
But one other question re-re-related to that.
So anti-trust.
>>Kamala Harris: Yes.
>>David: Competition law. So that's obviously
in an area that is not unknown to Google --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>David: and you're seeing state attorney
generals have become much more active in that
area. And to your last point about not standing
in the way, about making sure there's a balance
--
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: a lot of us are concerned sometimes
that in, given how quickly our-our industry
moves, how quickly things, there was when
I was first hanging around, hanging out with
Larry and Sergey 12 years ago, everybody thought,
"Search. Why are you doing a search start-up?"
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>David: That business is done, it's over.
>>David: There's nothing more to do there
and of course when in a few years people saw
it was very, very different.
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: And so things move so quickly. Mere
success at a given point at a snapshot in
time --
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: does not mean --
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>David: dominance or --
>>David: monopoly power and all those kinds
of things --
>>Kamala Harris: Or an era or anything [laughs]
--
>>David: or any of those things --
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>David: because these things can go away
--
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>David: in a heartbeat and that's why we
live sort of in fear of the-the --
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: the other folks in a garage somewhere.
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>David: So --
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs]
>>David: So what, how-how-how do you think
about that? I mean it's-it's --
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: it's, how do you think about enforcing
--
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: anti-trust and again you-you're,
if-if as you said it's happening here so there's
a-a-a big interest in the government state,
Government of California to make sure that
this industry is thriving --
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>David: So, I --
>>Kamala Harris: Absolutely right.
>>David: How do you strike this balance?
>>Kamala Harris: I think you've articulated
it. I mean it's-it-it really is, we cannot
be short-sighted --
>>David: No.
>>Kamala Harris: And so that's part of it
and-and so it is to recognize that we have
to allow the-these businesses to develop and
grow because that's where the models will
be created.
And-and it's also it's-it's incremental in
many ways to your point. This then grows to
its maximum potential and is the-the board
from which another thing leaps. And-and so
we have to understand these systems and how
they [unintelligible ].
And-and not do it again despite to save our
nose to spite our face because the other aspect
I think to your point, is this is a very significant
source of-of California's economy --
>>David: Yeah.
>>Kamala Harris: And if we, a state on the
verge of bankruptcy, want to do something
about that fact we're gonna have to recognize
we cannot stand in the way of business growth
and development.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: And that we don't have to
accept false choices. That doesn't --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: have to be to the exclusion--
>>Kamala Harris: for example, of protecting
consumers.
>>David: Yes.
>>Kamala Harris: It doesn't have to the exclusion
of going after bad businesses because bad
businesses are not good for good businesses.
>>David: Right. Right. Fair enough.
>>Kamala Harris: So.
>>David: Good. Well we've got some questions.
Why don't we start on this side of the room?
>>Justin Lieu: Sure. My name's Justin [Lieu]
and I was wondering if you thought three strikes
was Constitutional given that non-violent
offenders could get life sentences, and also
if you think it needs to be reformed in how
-- in either the law or how it's implemented
and, if so, how?
>>Kamala Harris: That's a great question Justin.
Thank you.
So it, three strikes is a law that came about-about
now 12 years ago in California. It was based
on that baseball analogy: third strike, you're
out. And it was, it came out of a horrible
case involving a little girl by the name of
Polly Klass who was horribly killed and turned
out the guy who did it had prior incidents
and so everyone said, "Well how could he have
been left to be on the street to do this one,
when he had done that kind of thing before?"
And there was an appropriate kind of emotional
response to her case but it ended up being
-- good public policy should not be driven
by emotion. And what ended up happening was
that a law was created and passed based on
an appropriate emotional reaction to what
happened to her, but it was written in such
a way that if a person had a serious and violent
first offense they'd do that time. If they
had a second one, they'd do twice the time.
And then if they had a third one, but the
law was written third of any kind of felony,
to your point even a non-violent, they would
do 25 to life.
I disagree with that. My policy in my office
is on my Website. It hasn't changed, which
is that we will not seek a 25 year to life
sentence unless the third offense is of a
serious or violent nature, with very few exceptions.
And-and-and there have been a number of case
law, cases that have come down to kind of
restrict the application of that one.
>>David: Great. Next question over here.
>>male in audience: Yeah, so obviously California
is pretty cash strapped at the moment and
will continue to be for the, in the years
ahead and I mean I recently learned that we're
also spending 11 percent of our budget on
prisons --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>male in audience: in keeping people incarcerated.
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: And, I mean, United States
also has one of the highest incarceration
rates in the world. I was wondering your thoughts
on the Attorney General's --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>male in audience: role in-in that issue
especially in the-the short term.
>>Kamala Harris: So I talked about Back on
Track, my initiative, which was absolutely
designed to deal with your point. We have
a seven out of ten rate of failure in terms
of the recidivism rate, 70 percent recidivate
within three years of their release in California.
Everyone would read about it on the front
page of the paper for the last several months:
"Oh my God, prisons are overflowing, they're
over crowded. Oh my God, there's gonna be
early release of prisoners." Problem, problem,
problem.
I would suggest to you that's not true. It's
a symptom of the problem. The problem is we
have a revolving door of crime in California
that we need to shut. So what am I talking
about?
The average prison sentence in California
is 24 months. You can infer two facts from
that: one, the average person being sentenced
to prison is not being sentenced for a-a serious
or violent crime because as we have discussed
with the three strikes question, it, that's
gonna be 10, 15, 25 to life. The other thing
that tells you, the other fact, they're all
coming out.
And we have no meaningful criminal justice
policy for dealing with that fact. So we're
just ostriches. So we lock 'em up. Good were
done with that guy. Well seven out of ten
of them are gonna go right back in and we
have no plan when they get out of prison after
serving their time for re-entering them.
So they do the predictable because, by the
way, since they committed the last crime,
the only changed circumstance is that they've
been in prison with a bunch of other folks.
[laughter]
Right?
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: So we have to have meaningful
criminal justice policy to deal with this
issue of recidivism to reduce the burden on
our criminal justice system which is costing
us to your point 10 billion dollars a year
in California, in a state that's on the verge
of bankruptcy.
So I believe one very discreet and specific
area of focus which would yield huge rewards
is to focus on the issue of recidivism, and
in particular, re-entering former offenders
and doing what we can to reduce the likelihood
that they will reoffend.
And then on the fiscal plan I will share with
you. It costs me $10,000 every time I prosecute
a felony. It costs us $35,000 a year to house
someone in the county jail. It costs $51,000
a year to house someone in the state prison.
My re-entry program, Back on Track, costs
less than $5,000 per participant. Right? And
you're having a, you're having an impact on
whole families when you do that work.
So again, it's back to the question about
the difference between me --
>>David: Yep.
>>Kamala Harris: and my opponent. I-I'm sure
someone would say, "Oh of course she's doing
that. That's not tough."
[pause]
Well I'm sorry so it's-it's just tough to
keep reacting to known, that you can just
predict they're gonna come out and just knock
'em right back in, knock 'em right back in.
[laughs] How 'bout shutting that door so they're
not going back in?
And that's what I'm talkin' about and I think
you are too.
>>male in audience: Yeah. Thank you.
>>David: Alright, next question over here
and I can predict, might be able to predict,
be able to predict what it'll be about.
>>Kamala Harris: [unintelligible]
>>male in audience: Actually I'm gonna --
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs]
>>male in audience: angle it off.
>>Kamala Harris: Okay.
>>David: Alright.
>>male in audience: So as many Googlers and
San Franciscans, I'm-I'm a pretty radical
civil libertarian --
>>Kamala Harris: Uh-huh.
>>male in audience: and that's hence my objection
to the --
>>Kamala Harris: Yes.
>>male in audience: attendance thing. But
can you give me a counter-example? Give me
an example where, 'cause to me your smart
also kind of means potentially ends justify
the means in terms of preventing crime ahead
of time. Can you give me an example of where
you've had a policy that you thought might
be effective --
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: but for civil liberty
reasons, privacy or intrusion into people's
lives, you've made the decision that that's
not a good policy for the-the state or the
city to be following?
>>Kamala Harris: Um.
>>male in audience: A-a time where you've-you've
sort of backed off on that and said, "You
know what> That's-that's too much, that's
too digging into people's lives?"
>>Kamala Harris: That's a wonderful question.
[pause]
The-the one that comes to mind and I'm sure
there-there's more than one. The one that
comes to mind most recently back to the question
was around the concern about known sexual
offenders using social networking sites.
And I was very much in favor of regulating
or restricting access. And when I started
to think more about it and received more information,
I realized that that would have been too expansive
and would have restricted a lot of people
who should not be restricted.
So what we did is I-I changed the definition
of social network sites to-to reflect more
the federal definition which would include
that there, it's a substantial number of -of
users are minors.
Looking at how we can, and then in terms of
which sex offenders, let's restrict that to
those that are most likely, so that-that is
probably one.
It would have been easy to go with the more
expansive one. It would have been politically
appear tougher, but-but I did reduce the-the
scope of the focus because of my concern for
your point.
And-and I, and I do wanna say something else
--
>>David: Yeah.
>>Kamala Harris: that I think is another good
distinction between me, another distinction
--.
>>David: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: between me and my opponent.
>>David: It's a campaign.
>>Kamala Harris: It's a campaign. No time
to be modest at all.
[laughter]
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs] We have 49 days
to go.
It's real, I see the role of this office,
Attorney General, as being very similar to
how I've tried to use my role as attorney,
as District Attorney. So there is the statutory
and technical responsibility of the office,
and then there is the bully pulpit that comes
with the office.
I have microphones in front of me all the
time. And hopefully I am educating myself
about issues and being informed by people
who understand issues more than I do. In a
way that when I'm in front of that bully pulpit,
I'm speaking in a responsible way and hopefully
educating the public.
And then the third role is-is-is the incredible
power that one has in these positions to convene,
which again is about bringing smart people
--
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: into the room to say, "Will
you all come together with me?" And then maybe
some people who are in a different component
of, or sector of our community or our lives,
come together around my table. I've done it
so many times, David.
>>David: Um.
>>Kamala Harris: Come together. Will you guys
come together for an hour? I've got an idea
and just come around my conference table and
let's play around with the idea.
And invariably in the course of that one hour
we are breaking through silos, but also during
the course of that one hour there is invariably
some plan for what we can do going forward
to be better, to be more effective, to-to
create synergy. And-and so I will say this,
I'm very comfortable admitting what I don't
know.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: And I, and I enjoy and I
am best when I make a decision after I have
heard from a lot of people. I like making
decisions like that. I like being surrounded
by smart people. I have no problem admitting
I don't know that.
And-and I think --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: you want that in your office
holders because the power we have, the power
I have as a prosecutor is that with a swipe
of my pen I can charge someone with a misdemeanor,
the lowest level offense possible. And by
virtue of that swipe of my pen you will have
to go to a courthouse and stand in line; you
will have to come out of pocket and hire an
attorney; you may get arrested for a few hours;
you will be embarrassed in your community;
you will miss time from coming on to the Google
Campus; all because with the swipe of my pen
I've charged you with a crime, which I may
choose to dismiss two weeks later.
It's an incredible amount of power. And you
wanna make sure that the people who have this
kind of power are taking seriously the responsibility
--
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: in terms of understanding
as much as anything the impact on the people
who will be impact, who will be affected by
that.
>>David: Absolutely.
Great. Great. Next question.
>>female in audience: You've outlined the
issues you consider important pretty clearly,
but from a practical perspective can you explain
or clarify some of the actions that you'll
take when you first come into of-office and
--
>>Kamala Harris: Sure.
>>female in audience: how you'll prioritize
them?
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah. That's great.
Well one of the first actions is I'm planning
on doing an audit [laughs] of the office and
I did that when I was first elected DA and
I'll tell you why, many reasons. But mostly
because when you come in as the head of a-an
organization, there will be a bunch of squeaky,
squeaky wheels which will demand a lot of
your attention and time. They're are gonna
be just banging cymbals and-and-and invariably
though when you look into it, you will find
that it's the guy who's down the hall and
around the corner under that green visor that
is the one's who's actually making the whole
train run.
And if you start making decisions about how
you're gonna prioritize resources, how are
you gonna distribute resources around what
is-is obvious, you're probably gonna make
some mistakes.
So the first thing that you-you always have
to do in these offices and this gets back
to the-the seemingly mundane which is absolutely
critical to doing the broad sweeping work
to the point of your question. You have to
know where everything is. And-and you have
to figure that out pretty quickly so that
you can then start to make the decisions that
are consistent with your policy priorities.
So that's one of the first actions I plan
on taking.
>>David: Okay. Hopefully we can, you have,
you have time for, to --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah. Yeah, absolutely.
>>David: get these last --
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah, absolutely.
>>David: three questions.
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>David: Okay.
>>Kamala Harris: Yes, absolutely.
>>David: Let's go here and there and back
again.
>>Joanne Syben: Okay. Hi, my name is Joanne
Syben and I have a question for you about
the cost of incarceration --
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>Joanne Syben: versus apprenticeships and
the context is I've been reading a number
of studies lately that suggest that despite
our grievous unemployment figures, we actually
are suffering a shortage of highly skilled
blue collar workers --
>>Kamala Harris: Absolutely.
>>female in audience: electricians, plumbers,
solar technicians, auto mechanics, etcetera.
>>Kamala Harris: Um-hum.
>>female in audience: So could you compare,
a two-part question. Could you compare the
cost of incarceration versus apprenticeship
programs? And given that it seems so blatantly
obviously a good solution all around, why
have such programs failed to gain a huge amount
of traction so far? Is it lack of leadership?
Political will? Funding? What's going on?
[laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: And you're talking about
around skills development around known offenders?
>>female in audience: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah. So the cost. The cost
is like I was saying' for Back on Track, for
example, $10,000 to prosecute a felony, $35,000
a year to house somebody in the country jail,
$51,000 a year to house someone in state prison.
My Initiative Back on Track costs less than
$5,000 per participant. And it includes not
just a skills development but it actually
looks at the participants in a, in a, in a
holistic way understanding their lives are
as multi-faceted as ours.
So it's about their need for child care, their
need for housing, their need for clearing
up their credit, some basic stuff.
I would say that part of the problem, I'm
a little bit of a nerd, and-anyway I've done
a study of the criminal justice system in
the United States [laughs] and just simply
put there was one, once upon a time there
was this thing called the war on poverty.
But it was really, it was a great idea and
it was really short-lived. And then it became
the war on crime and then it became the war
on drugs.
Then there was this guy by the name of Michael
Dukakis that decided to run for President
of the United States and it turned out this
guy Michael Dukakis had been Governor of this
state called Massachusetts, and when he was
Governor there was this guy by the name of
Willy Horton who was on a furlough program
that was a job training program. And this
guy Horton went out and committed a horrendous
crime and then this other guy Michael Dukakis
because of that, lost the election.
And [laughs] all of a sudden the word "rehabilitation"
was synonymous with soft on crime. And all
of a sudden, and I'm -- this is the general
kind of crude analysis, but true. You can
track it and see all of a sudden, it was not
the tough thing to talk about when you wanted,
when you talked about the crime problem to
talk about a focus on rehabilitation as part
of the solution. And it was abandoned.
And frankly to be very candid with you all,
I rarely use the word "rehabilitation". I
talked about "reduction of recidivism" 'cause
it just lost its-its-its true meaning. It
became soft on crime. It became, let me tell
you a word you've probably never heard that
I've heard in many circles. It's a "hug-a-thug"
program.
>>David: Huh.
[laughter]
>>Kamala Harris: Isn't that the most offensive
term you've ever heard? It's a hug-a-thug
program.
>>David: [unintelligible]
>>Kamala Harris: This is the mindset and so
you have where we are now. And-and so back
to the question from the, from the fellow
who was over here. So we're much more prepared
to put $10 billion a year in California into
locking people up instead of into a holistic
approach.
And by the way, nothing I'm saying should
be confused to be anything other than saying
-- when somebody commits a crime they must
be held accountable. I've spent my whole life
locking people up. So I'm not suggesting you
let people get away with it. I'm not suggesting
that people shouldn't go to jail.
But there are cycles and there are systems
and we have to look beyond the one criminal
case and we have to look at the crime problem.
And that's how criminal justice policy should
be designed.
>>David: It sounds like you're describing
a lack of political courage and a lack of
political will. How do you break through that?
>>Kamala Harris: Or creativity.
>>David: Or even creativity. But how-how,
but if that's, if-if basically the view is
you don't get elected if you talk about this
stuff or if you try to do these things maybe
you-you'll-you'll get run out of office. How-how's
it ever gonna happen?
>>Kamala Harris: I think that people are smarter
than we give them credit for.
>>David: Okay.
>>Kamala Harris: I think that if you start
talking about it in a way that, I mean here's
the other part of what's -- let me tell you
why I wrote the book. I wrote the book 'cause
I was, I wrote it in hoping it would be ready
in time for the Denver convention, for the
Democratic Convention when we elected the
President.
Because I was so sure that there was gonna
be this robust debate on criminal justice
policy and so I wanted to hopefully help inform
that debate. And of course there was no debate
on criminal justice policy --
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: because to talk about criminal
justice policy is to assume such a prickly
subject if you're gonna be reasonable --
>>David: Hum.
>>Kamala Harris: then nobody wants to bring
it up.
>>David: Right.
>>Kamala Harris: And, but that being said,
I have -- as the Democrat from San Francisco
in the primary with six opponents, we took
L.A., we took Orange County, we took Fresno,
we took San Diego.
>>David: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: And I have stood in living
rooms in Riverside and-and in Orange County
and places that are considered conservative
and talked about these issues and people get
it. I think when you talk to people in a way
that is just about what is pragmatic and realistic
and it's about just not about ideology, they
get it and so I'm willing to take that risk.
>>David: Right.
Let's try to get the last two questions in
quickly.
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>David: Right over here.
>>female in audience: It'll be really quick.
I'm on the --
>>Kamala Harris: My answer probably won't
be. [laughs]
>>female in audience: It probably will be.
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs]
>>female in audience: I'm on the Online Media
Team here at Google and you mentioned that
there is no other way to reach voters other
than through TV.
>>David: That's a question I have.
[laughter]
>>David: We beg to differ.
>>female in audience: Have you explored the
media tools that we have here at Google?
[laughter]
>>Kamala Harris: Will you help me?
>>female in audience: Absolutely.
>>Kamala Harris: Okay. Come-come sit up here
or we'll find you after. I mean that though.
I really do. 'Cause I'm sure we have not as-as
much as we should. Thank you. Thank you.
That's great.
>>David: Last question over here. [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: [laughs]
[applause]
>>male in audience: My question is going to
be somewhat in-in a similar vein.
>>Kamala Harris: Oh good.
>>male in audience: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: Good. I want your help too.
[laughs]
>>male in audience: So-so my question is I
mean you obviously talk about bringing the
criminal justice system from the 20th century
into the 21st century.
>>Kamala Harris: Yeah.
>>male in audience: And of course some of
the common examples of email and so forth
and connectivity --
>>Kamala Harris: Right.
>>male in audience: there are-are obviously
resounding. But I mean are there other concrete
things that which are perhaps sort of leading
edge or bleeding edge that you're, that you're
thinking about and how you, are-are you thinking
about enlisting some of these or the-the most
innovative-innovative companies in the, in
the space or in the Valley to sort of help
lead that in-in-in that and set a model for
the country as a, or maybe even-even more
broadly?
>>Kamala Harris: Absolutely.
>>male in audience: As opposed to completely
leading from the political side which obviously
--
>>Kamala Harris: Oh no I don't think it can
happen that way. I agree with you completely.
It can't happen that way and-and absolutely.
I've been wanting to come to the Google Campus
for a year and a half.
>>David: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: Let me just be clear about
that. I'm so happy I'm here right now.
>>male in audience: Um-hum.
>>Kamala Harris: But I've been wantin' to
come because I want these relationships. And
I wanna cultivate them because I want you
to be an advisory group.
And I want you, I wanna be able to say, "Look
guys this is what I've got. Tell me from -- what
do you see as the way that we get to where
we need to be? What does the design look like?"
And that's gonna be around everything in terms
of how we're communicating online to what
we're doing around creating systems that are
about keeping and warehousing information
and data to what we can be doing around just
upgrading all of the-the-the pure kind of
communication systems that-that exist and
should exist within government. So we can
increase accountability and effectiveness
and reduce human error and all of that.
And I-I am positive that the skill set to
be able to get where we need to be is not
gonna be inside necessarily. It's gonna be
about our friends coming in to give the help
and the assistance to-to upgrade us. And-and
so I agree with you completely.
And it is, I love having advisory committees.
I have a few that I rely on completely and
on this issue of technology there's no question
that, and-and this is what I meant earlier
about my pride about being in California where
this is a short drive to come here. This is
you, this is backyard, we're family.
>>David: [laughs]
>>male in audience: [chuckles]
>>Kamala Harris: And-and so --
>>male in audience: [laughs]
>>Kamala Harris: Right?
>>David: yes.
>>Kamala Harris: And so-so it-it-it California
AG should be a leader on these issues. Yeah.
>>David: Great. Well, everyone thank-thanks
so much and Kamala, it's great to have you
here.
[applause]
You really, really [unintelligible].
Let's make sure it doesn't take a year and
a half for the next time and you're welcome
--
>>Kamala Harris: That's not your fault.
>>David: You're welcome anytime.
>>Kamala Harris: Thank you. Thank you.
>>David: And thanks to everybody. Great questions.
>>Kamala Harris: Thank you all. And we'll
find that woman --
[music]
Me and my friends were all misunderstood.
They say we stop for nothin' and there's no
way we ever could.
Now we see everything that's goin' wrong
With the world and those who lead it
Just feel like we don't have the means
To rise above and feed it.